counselors we're now live on youtube
thank you very much chris and uh good
morning and welcome to the
team british district council executive
on the 6th of april
and all welcome and i hope you all have
a lovely easter
and enjoy the great weather can i ask if
you're not speaking if you just put your
microphones on mute
until you do speak please um we'll go
through just to make sure everyone's
here and take any apologies so
would you uh organize that please yeah i
do roll call now thanks leader
councillor connet i'm president
councillor dew herst
present councillor jackie hook president
councillor keeling present
councillor jefferies
present councillor mcgregor
president councillor persa present
councillor taylor councillor wrigley
present
um so there is a part two on today's
agenda
um for the future high streets fund and
what i want to say to colleagues is i
suspect
most of the conversation can be held in
open session because that's where the
bulk of the report is but if you
know now that you're going to need to
refer to the part two item
or if during the course of debate you
need to
please let me know and then we'll go
formally into part two for that
consideration
and then we'll go back into part one to
complete the
uh discussion in open session and that's
where the decisions have been made all
right
so please don't relax into discussing
the exact information
in the open part of the meeting all
right so you want to be clear about that
now we've got a uh counselor mike
hawkins asked to speak on the future
street fund
so when we get to that item i'm gonna
ask uh mike
to speak and then there's a presentation
and then in fairness to mike uh i'm just
going to let him
uh speak again if there's anything that
he needs to say
in light of the presentation and then
we'll go to
council jeffrey's executive councillor
and then the
executive discussion uh before the
recommendations
um since the agenda was published
uh some of the recommendations have been
sort of tightened up and slightly
changed in the presentation you're going
to see at the start the track
changes so you can see what was sent
back with the papers and what the
proposal is
and then towards the end of the
presentation there'll be a clean set
of recommendations all right so i just
need to make sure
that everyone knows that and it's not a
surprise during the course of the event
anyway let's move on to the next item
which is the minutes
and there to approve the minutes of the
meeting on the 2nd of march and
now i'll take a proposal in a second
please
so we'll take councillor keeling as a
proposer a mayor of a secondary
mcgregor is the second and are we all in
favor or if anyone's not say so now
so we're going to take that as the
unanimous then we're all in favor of the
minutes thank you very much
um are there any declarations of
interest as opposed to interesting
things to declare
are there any declarations of interest
no so there are no declarations of
interest and then to note
that the forward plan managed to ask if
we'll agree to note the forward
yeah that's lovely thank you very much
uh item five then
the public questions and i don't think
there are any honors sarah
i have no public questions that's fine
thank you very much so we move on to
item six which is the
executive key decision so this is the
devon
home choice policy review and uh we go
to uh councillor wrigley as the
executive council
uh thank you leader so um devon home
choice is a scheme
of housing allocation that is run by a
partnership of other local authorities
districts and unitary across devon
and all of the registered providers of
affordable and social homes
team bridge uses devon home choice to
enable the fair allocation of homes
and satisfy the legal requirements under
various acts and statutory guidance
representatives from each partner sits
on the devon home choice
management board so devin helm choice
provides a common scheme across devon
with a common application form and
approach
to advertising properties assessing
housing need
and awarding priority
today we are asked to consider a set of
changes that have come from the
management board discussions
and all the approval from all of the
participating authorities
these changes were put to a public
consultation between november 2020 and
january this year
um but i'd just like to draw your
attention to the team bridge housing
register
as of march this year first of march
this year in appendix two of the report
this shows the recurring pattern of a
register of some 1000 households needing
a new home
and despite team bridge allocating some
400 homes each year
we see a small increase in the waiting
list each year
this highlights the need for team bridge
100 program to deliver more genuinely
affordable homes across the district
adding to the delivery from the section
106 allocations
this snapshot of the register also shows
that some 50
of the need is for one bedroom
accommodations
about 26 percent for two bedroom 17
for three bedroom and the remainder for
four and above
in the light of that we have eight
proposals on the table today
which are summarized on page 19 of the
report and please note that proposals
six and seven are not included for today
there was a member briefing recently on
devon home choice and how it operated
and that answered many questions and
today's alterations in policy
are designed to alleviate some quite
specific issues that have arisen across
the country
uh county and you will see that several
of them relate to
how need for larger numbers of bedrooms
are assessed so that we can smooth out
the houses that we have and the need
for people with a variety of the larger
number of bedrooms
um i would like to put forward that we
uh accept this as
uh as set out and um uh
let it go back to uh devon home choice
thank you thank you very much for that
um
councillor wrigley um is there an
officer president who also may want to
add anything
uh martin i believe tammy hayes is here
all right
okay tommy um welcome and is there
anything
uh that you'd like to add to what uh
council wrigley is uh
said by way of introduction well um hi
i'm for those that don't know me i'm
tommy hayes i
oversee the running of devon home choice
um i think councillor wrigley has summed
it up perfectly i don't think i have
anything
further to add to it okay so can i ask a
couple of questions in relation to the
two proposals
which have been deferred or rejected
that's proposal six and proposal seven
um proposal six is deferred does that
mean it's going to come back to all of
the partner councils
for some confirmation when devon home
choice board has
made a decision about it uh and is
proposal seven
definitely off never to be seen again
uh proposals there will be a task there
a working group
to have a look at the implications of it
needs more work before we could make
a uh an informed change on the policy so
yes yes right and what i'm checking is
when devon ham choice when a final
decision is made is that going to come
back to the partner councils for a
decision
or what happens to it yeah if we were
going to
put forward and accept of proposal six
and we were going to look to change it
we can bring that back
thank you all right and proposal seven
is
is basically in the recycling bin i take
it
at this time yes that worries me when
you say that but
anyway it won't it won't be implemented
until it won't be
implemented that's right not until we've
done any further work on it but six will
do a work in group seven looks to be
shelved
lovely thank you very much and then um i
just want to take colleagues to
uh page seven on the report and this is
the
legal implications which have been set
out by the council solicitor
and this is just notes and i think i
want to draw members attention to it
because
i'm sure either martin or tommy can just
clarify
he says it is assumed they're not clear
in the report that this is being
addressed this is about the consultation
um and can you just assure us that the
consultation with the registered
providers
was or has taken place uh leader the
registered providers are part of the
management
team that have put this forward so all
the registered providers are included
within this as far as i understand it
we're not here in effect they've
consulted themselves and we've consulted
them so
exactly that's part of it you know
there's no impediment to us adopting
uh the change none that i'm aware of
lovely thank you for that uh so
colleagues
you've heard what council wrigley said
and what uh the officer has said as well
uh martin has proposed might have a
secondary please and councillor taylor
is secondly
any questions from colleagues
no in that case might take a vote all
those in favor
yeah we're all in favor anyone has any
concerns
no we're all in failure and that's
unanimous sarah
thank you very much so uh now we're
going to move
to item seven which is a notice of
motion
uh referred from the previous council on
the 22nd of february to us
and this is a motion submitted by uh
councillor hook and i'm going to invite
gordon now to speak to his motion gordon
thanks so much good morning thanks alan
um
yeah i i i hope we can agree that you
know it's right to give thanks and it's
it's
good to show appreciation and to
recognize the voluntary effort on behalf
of
the community on behalf of others
but we are we're living through
extraordinary times experiencing
trauma on a scale previously not
experienced for
well i don't know at least for 80 years
many within our communities have
come forward and performed quite
remarkable acts displaying
generosity of spirit commitment to their
fellow man
a strong desire to help this has
certainly been the case during the
ongoing pandemic
but of course it's not unique by any
stretch of the imagination or restricted
to the recent problems faced as a
consequence of
coronavirus many offer their
time energy knowledge to help promote a
vast range of activities youth sport
the arts support of the elderly
the hungary the the disabled and and
the lonely and so on it's an almost
endless list of people who are helping
in in various
ways in various directions in my opinion
we should recognize as a number of local
authorities do
the contribution made by the voluntary
charitable sector
in an official way i am asking that a
group of
members volunteers
come forward to consider the best ways
of doing this
my offering to that debate by no means
not open to 100 other suggestions would
be
to invite town in paris councils but
equally
offer the opportunity to members of the
public to nominate either individuals
or organizations for the award of a team
bridge district council
certificate which would acknowledge the
particular contribution made
and in so doing give thanks on behalf of
the community
for that contribution an appointed group
could then evaluate nominations i have a
number of ideas
to to flesh out the outline proposal
which i
won't trouble you with now but it would
be another way of building better closer
community relations across the district
i i would suggest
this certificate could be presented by
the chair of the council
at an annual reception i could go on but
i but i very much hope members
across the chamber will support the
proposal and we can take it forward
thank you um
thank you gordon i i think your comments
are uh
are well received um some of what you
said isn't within the scope of the
motion you put to cancel
uh and we'll we'll pick that up in a
moment but i i think we would all
endorse
very much your comments um apart from
all of the excellent work that many
organizations have done almost
uncertainly there are
well i would say millions of untold and
unknown
acts of human kindness between
neighbours and communities
which go on every day and
unremarked and people just doing the
right thing
for in their area for their community
and i think all of us and everyone has
been absolutely amazed by
that warmth uh which is one of the good
things which has come out of the past
uh year or so isn't it uh i'm going to
move to councillor wrigley who's the
executive council responsible for
oversight of our sort of community work
martin
um thank you leader i mean i i fully
endorse uh
councillors councillor hook's words here
because
as you say there have been so many
people that have come together and i
think the sense of
community that has been built uh through
the pandemic
is astonishing the
individual acts of people has been truly
tremendous as well as the organizations
that have
stepped up and and i fully support the
idea
of having um some annual awards i think
um
cvs have done some in the past i'm not
sure if they've been every year
i certainly remember going to sort of
recognition
ceremonies with cvs so i'd like to make
sure that we don't
tread on their toes in terms of of of
devaluing that
um interesting idea about getting the
towns and um
parishes to put put people forward i
know a number already do
civic awards certainly that that happens
uh here in dulish
so we want to make sure that we either
um add
around those or again don't detract from
those
i would have a question though of how we
find people who may not be necessarily
put through the the towns and parachutes
is this something that we should be
opening up to a wider sort of nomination
process as well not sure if you're
frozen we'll just stop there martin
uh no no no i i just sourced there to
see
where counselor
just hold on i'll give you a chance to
come back but i've got some other
speakers
and marching band whether you have
frozen or not that was a great place to
stop but uh just to let you know i've
got three people so far
uh stephen purser andrew mcgregor and
alistair jr says stephen
uh thank you leader um i fully endorse
uh what what councilor hook is is is
aiming to do
and your comments and also councillor
wrigley's comments
um it's one of those times when
so many people have done so many acts of
kindness
it would be an almost invidious task i
feel
to try and select
individuals who should get a certificate
as opposed to
almost global certificates you know my
i have a neighbor who's called on a an
old boy next door and made sure
he's alive and fed and watered and has
food
who clearly would would be one of many
thousands across the district who in my
opinion would be sort of
eligible for for such a certificate and
i just
i just wonder the practicality of of
trying
to do all that often with people who
don't wish to perhaps be acknowledged
um i i think it's a very laudable and a
very
good idea and we need to do some form of
recognition but
but sorry being sort of the
practicalities of getting to
all those individuals i i see as as a
major
problem that we would have to try and
solve equitably
so nobody felt sort of hardly done by or
not done by
uh in the process thank you stephen i'm
going to come to
andrea next yeah andrew
thank you chair i think aleister was in
before me but um as soon as i've got the
floor i'll take it
um in terms of um
what team bridge already do we've had
sport and community awards for a number
of years
obviously the covid crisis has knocked
the bottom out of that
in in both in terms of being able to
acknowledge people
um do the do the work or even people
carrying out the work in
in the sports area particularly working
with communities so
from that perspective we already have a
sort of framework
um in place that we we could use for it
um
the big question of course then at that
point is the in in the reality of thing
is
that we were looking to reduce cost so
we'd need to find a way of financing a
process like this because it would be
quite expensive
as as stephen has pointed out we are
talking potentially about thousands of
people working through
names etc to to narrow it down so
they're going to be resources used etc
to get this now i'm not saying that we
shouldn't be recognizing these people
because we have
traditionally done so but it's just that
you know the more we add into the mix
the more
the cost grows so perhaps we need to
look at what we do currently or what we
have done
in the past and modify what we've done
there and then use that model going
forward
to recognize the community lovely thank
you
andrew alistair
good morning thank you leader um so i i
actually remember
in the last lib dem independent
administration uh that we actually did a
similar thing
uh and i believe it was open
to a number of organizations to promote
people
and also to us as district councillors
uh
to to also uh do the same and
um i'm not convinced that it was uh
particularly expensive
i seem to remember that those uh
fantastically worthy people got a nice
certificate
um which i i believe was printed in
house
uh and um and access to some nibbles
and soft drinks um and a few speeches
were made but but i still
i still remember and i know that those
people that i personally
uh took to the event um remember it to
this day
and and their community remembers it um
so so for me i i really think this would
be a fantastic thing
um i i could almost nominate just about
every single person in my community
because
everybody's worked together but i can
think of a of a few stars
uh who i would really really like uh
to to publicly acknowledge uh for their
fantastic work
um done quietly
in the background but but amazingly
amazing work so so for me um i
i would very much want to support this
well i'm i'm sure we all do i'll come
back to march in a moment i think
to an extent i agree that it does
require further thinking about because
it's not just about volunteers it's also
about people who've
quietly been getting on with their job
the social care workers the vaccinators
the nhs staff
the policemen the firemen the council
staff
you know so where did you start where'd
you start uh but almost certainly and
um one of the things that occurs to me
is that
we are still in the pandemic we still
can't meet we still can't meet indoors
but the time when we might and i
think um what councilor junior says that
if we're going to do something
doing it well and doing it right uh it
might be worth waiting for but martin
you know johanna alastair can you take
your hand down
thanks uh thank you leader i was
actually going to suggest something very
similar there because
there's there's a number of things that
um that i'm aware of and clearly i'd
forgotten about the sports awards that
uh council mcgregor reminds us of i
think councillor dewhurst is absolutely
right about the uh
the ceremonies and going to do there
there's there's you know
old fort house is a lovely place to hold
um hold such things and do things but
we are of course still in the grips of
the pandemic
i know the uh we even had the prime
minister saying that you know he was
worried about a third wave and so i
think we need to be
cautious i think this is a scheme that
we should
do and i think it's something that we
should do well but i think we need to
look into it design it work out how we
get around some of the issues that uh
you know such as council person was
suggesting that
similarly i could nominate just about
everybody in the town
uh um before this um so i think
a little bit of conversation with the
other organizations seeing how it fits
in
seeing how we can organize it and make
it something
special um and fair
so i'd like to propose that um
i take it away and report back um in a
few months time
um as to what we might be able to do and
uh put some
put some um
what's the phrase i'm looking for meet
around the frame put some put some
details in place um having consulted
with the with the other bodies
um as much as possible so that we can
put something in place
when we can safely bring people together
again
so thanks for that margin so as this
there was a motion that went to council
it was moved and then referred to
executive considerations so we make a
recommendation
back to council so can i can i suggest a
way forward for everyone
and in particular some of what uh gordon
had said wasn't actually in his motion
um so we're trying we're trying to
embrace it
and deal with emotion and then what
clearly is
the mood of the mood of members uh so
item one on the motion was about
team which council placing on record its
gratitude to
all sectors of the volunteering chapter
or sectors of the voluntary and
charitable sector i think we all agreed
with that
so we support that uh item two was
acknowledged in the work of the many
organizations communities individuals
who have contributed at this uniquely
difficult time and i think you know
that's absolutely fine it's a statement
of fact
we would support that and
what i'm going to suggest is that we ask
the cancers communications team to do
a news release and to put something on
the council website as it's imperative
it's absolutely perfect because it can't
quote the counsellor which is very very
good isn't it
and so this would be a non-political
thank you on behalf of the council of
everyone
and that's a really standard thing to do
because i'm sure all councillors and all
staff
will want to do that so we can do that
and martin can ask you to
pick that up uh with um the
communications team
uh then we get to the the ask the
original ask in gordon's
uh motion which was we further asked the
ons uh earlier scrutiny committee to
consider ways in which
this council may work even more
constructively with the sector
in the future uh so that was the
original ask
uh we'll come to the new ask you know
that was the original ask what i'm going
to suggest is picking up on what
council wrigley said and obviously the
news today is
uh while lockdown is lifting uh you know
there's talk of a possible third
lockdown so what i'm going to suggest is
that we would recommend
that we look again at that
when we have better clarity around where
the country is and
and what work might be needed on that so
that would be my proposal
and then we'll add in four which is the
new proposal
uh so gordon's mission creep isn't where
which is about a factory event
and i think we'll we'll pick up
councillor wrigley's proposal on that
which
uh uh you know council um
agrees with the principle of a thank you
event or
process uh and uh um
councillor wrigley and the team are
asked to look at how that may happen
and report back to a future meeting of
the council
so um that's the proposal i think
amending may i take a second
for that please uh well
i've got several hazard we'll take
cancer persa uh as a second after that
and is everyone gordon i promise to come
back to you i do apologize
i do promise gordon i wouldn't
particularly know you've heard what the
proposal will be to counsel
thank you can you hear me all right yeah
absolutely no jolly good no
let me thank thank you for the debate
and thank you for the comments and
they're all
without exception valid i mean this this
is
this is trying to kick something off
trying to start something
which absolutely needs consideration
absolutely needs um input from
different directions and i i would
absolutely support that i
i offer it as a as a starting point and
nothing more
i just think it's got potential i just
think it's got um
i just think it's got you know
possibilities and and it would be good
to explore them i certainly don't want
to
cause any great expenditure and that is
not the intention at all it's just a
good will
gesture it's just looking at people who
have made
i think i take the point that i think it
says i'm not sure i think it's stephen
making about his next-door neighbor
helping an elderly gent well that's
that's lovely and that's going on
you know wholesale and and wonderful
that it is i'm thinking rather more of
of impact on the community although um
i think again it was probably that
whoever it was spoke first might have
been
martin who um suggested that um
you know we did we didn't want to tread
on other people's toes who were doing
some
something similar and yes of course
that's absolutely right
i i do know that the voluntary sector is
is um
enthused by this um if i might say so
by this suggestion so there would be
support
in that direction um uh
i think somebody said about extending
the rights of nomination i i said in my
comments that it would be a way of
linking with town in paris councils but
sorry mr gordon i was hoping you might
just summarize rather than take the
opportunity to
expand further your mission creep sorry
i
i'm grateful for the comments made i
look forward to it going forward
i hope i might play a part in that god
bless you all
thank you for your time
thank you so um with gordon's blessings
uh are you all content with the uh
revised
recommendation uh to counsel uh
so we've got i proposed uh stephen
seconded are we all in front of them
all right anyone against uh
so that's wonderful thank you that's
unanimous uh and sarah hopefully you've
got that down
i've got a squiggly note here okay so
thank you very much gordon for
bringing it to cancer it's much
appreciated thank you
um right so we'll move now to the uh
future high street fan which is set
on pages 25 to 114 and just the course
from the game that if you
uh do need to refer to the part 2 report
let me know we're going to exempt
session so everyone can discuss that at
the time but i suspect
probably members won't need to do that
so before we take the presentation i'll
go
straight to council hawking mike
yeah thank you for allowing me to uh to
speak
um probably some of the stuff i want to
say will probably be a little bit out of
zinc
bearing in mind your preamble at the
beginning of this meeting that
things might have changed or moved on a
little bit since when they report
what was made um having read through the
report
it is clear to me that this was written
in such a way as to tick government
boxes
in order for this council to satisfy
this government's grand scheme
namely the future high street fund
i see it as a way for this council to
obtain money
to generate the market hall instead of
using its own capital to finance a
scheme
which has been on the table now for for
a few years i cannot condemn the count
i can't condemn tdc for this what i do
condemn is the way in which
council is using queen street and the
unpopular ideas of
removing parking by narrowing the road
to such an extent
that restricts movement of delivery
vehicles and people just wanting
park pop and shock even even now
when vehicles are parked on the right
hand side designated bays
passage is restricted when a large
delivery vehicles are carrying out their
lawful duties
i do however support some of the things
within the report
like one in the footpaths in queen
street to make it easier for people to
move around
on foot but do we do we need to do such
a do we need to do this to such an
extent
as to allow cafe seating areas do we
need to plant trees
bearing in mind the problems we have now
with trees in courtney street
yes by all means let's have shrubs and
and planted areas
but these must be looked after and not
left to so
to look like the ones again in queen in
courtney street
the joining up with an enhancement of
the national cycleway
but i do question the impact that this
will have on the town center
and therefore the benefits to businesses
we could be spending a lot of money a
lot of public money
for little public and or business game
but then yet again this will tick boxes
at a briefing tdc officers gave to the
tang council just a few weeks ago
there was a lot of opposition to the
queen street part of the bed the times
man development manager was quite
outspoken as she put
forward the feelings of queen street
businesses who will
who will be affected by the loss of
short-term parking
and the subsequent loss of pop-in
shoppers
but i can see no mention of this in the
report just a few
figures from the survey tdc carried out
and as we all know figures from surveys
can be made to
make to look in favor of per person can
be maybe to look in the favor
of the person or the organization asking
the questions
if they didn't then the survey would not
be used to support the argument
going on to the proposals a proposed
upgrade of the market hall
by joining the inside to the alexander
theater
we can all agree that something needs to
be done
but making this one large open space
with little sock units at one end
some removable market stalls in the
middle and a bar come restaurant the
other
in my opinion is not how i see or market
progressing forward over the next
20 years or so we have seen over the
last 30 years now
how the market has gone downhill traders
finding it more difficult to compete
with
supermarkets and plant shops and now
with the increased desire to buy online
i feel their challenge to survive is
even more greater
tingbridge have not performed well over
recent years
in letting out the market stalls or
little units which are now along the
side
and i ask myself what will change or
will this trend continue
even after spending several million
pounds on its conversion
is this just going to be torquay's white
elephant
but in newt nava tingbridge
are still struggling to let all units in
market walk
and our old post office is still a
disused shell
perhaps we should concentrate on this
before embarking on new projects
the new proposed cinema is if the
drawings are to believed
to me that is two shipping containers
one on top the other
not the sort of thing i wish to see in
my tank center
surely now it deserves better we only
have to look at
look at tingma to see what can be done
the alexander although built to the coin
exchange was converted to a
cinema strokes theater and is the only
surviving theater out of three
might be four but three that i know of
still in newt never
and yes i am sure we can all see that
this building is not fit for purpose
in the 21st century but it could be
i could go on forever making comments on
this report
but i will not i do not feel that this
is the right way for tdc to go
on the regeneration of our time and
although i will not vote against it for
council
i will not support it the reason i have
spoken today
is to put on record my view and i hope
you will
over the coming months consider the harm
that this proposal
in my opinion will cause cambridge over
the years have not done nickname
any favors in how they have allowed
developers to destroy
in hindsight i know the market town
image of old
from the mid 70s when it allowed the
market area to be knocked down and
rebuilt
with the market walk we have today
just look at the picture on page 61 of
your report
and note how the market hall stood proud
within the center of the town
and no matter how much money you throw
at the inside now
this product cannot be brought back asda
had a contract which we all welcomed at
the time to build a supermarket on the
seymour
horror site as a gateway to the town
but chose to but chose to go against
that contract and build
where it is today it is my view
tinbridge
by agreeing to let us down by agreeing
to this
let us down and we are now left with an
ugly fenced-off
hole in the ground where this gateway
should have been
we are now faced with tingbridge being
the developer and i
i would hate history to seek to see this
as yet another letdown for the time
yes the town needs to grow and look
forward to a future
but we also need to learn the lessons of
the past
this report and its recommendations will
go through as no one will want
want us to do 9.2 million of free money
but i do not believe that this is the
right way to go i have had my doubts
from the beginning
over all the plans that have come
forward from many of us many so-called
experts
on how we should regenerate and i can't
see how
tweaking along the edges as this plant
this plan report is suggesting
will repair and move us forward from the
faults inherited
in the past thank you uh
thank you right um thanks mike for
and that pick up things in general
conversation but we're going to move now
to the
uh presentation uh neil
would you like to uh start uh yes
uh good morning councillors if i can
before i get into it um
there are some minor tweaks to the
recommendation that i'd like to put
forward
okay so apologies it's come in so late
to have um comments back from
the legal team so if i can just share my
screen uh
with you so it's um
hopefully
can you all see that yeah so it should
be the word document so there's nothing
fundamentally
changing to to the recommendation but it
is uh
more clarity on what specifically we're
asking executive to do
today and also what were requested of
the
full council when they meet on the 22nd
um
of april
oops sorry
so the first bit is is just finalizing
the detail of uh
saying that we accept the the bid for
the funding
um we were hoping to have had that
funding confirmed
by now um we were told end of march was
when we're going to be receiving
that confirmation but we've been told
now it's likely to be mid-april
the uh that's the first sort of minor
change the next part is
is um on the uh
the recommendations three to six is
being more specific both in reference
and
um where in the report you can find more
detail but also
the amount that we're asking um for
uh budget to to be included um
and so it's uh i mean this this is all
the budget
and the finances are set out in our
submission to the future high street
funds
those budgets do include contingency so
there isn't an anticipation that would
need to come back
for for any variations on that and it's
just being clear that what we're asking
for
full council is to agree the budget
those budgets
have already been included uh in the
annual budget setting
um and so there's nothing additional
being requested that we haven't already
made
plans for um and it's also worth
pointing out the
the the sources of those budgets just in
case anyone was
was interested in so it's a mixture of
community infrastructure levy section
106 money from planning applications
um presidential borrowing there'll be
elements
of projects that haven't carried on that
we'll move budget across
to to include on all of that um
and then the final point is just an
amendment
to bullet seven um
about being clear that what we're
looking for is
um sort of the delegated authority to to
to prepare the plans and develop the
details in line with the appendix
e which sets up the time scales for the
delivery of
all of these projects um which is in
line with the future high street funds
time scale as well so the money that we
get needs to be spent by a
um end of march 2024
so we've got quite the tight timescale
in which to bring this all forward
so that's the recommendation uh and the
proposed amendments i've got a clean
copy that i can share
with everybody at the end if you're
happy to accept those changes
so fine thank you for neil yes i think
that ties it up and in fact it's clearer
in terms of what the recommendations
might be from the executive to council
uh later in the month so shall we move
on into that presentation
okay yeah thank you um and so
uh okay so in i'll i'll lead through
this presentation just to give everybody
an overview
uh and a bit of a background of where
we've come from and i'll pick up council
hawking's points about
some of the changes these are um bits of
work that have been going on for some
time so i thought it'd be quite useful
for the executive and
and we'll look to present this again to
full council
um just to give you the overview of
where we've come from and where we've
got to
um and at the end we can take any
questions and it'd be myself and also on
the call today
is tom butcher louisa brinton and the
stell skinner who
are all leading on the the component
part of the project so any detailed
questions that you may have
they'll join the call and i may defer to
them for further detail
so we can just go through the
presentation this is a a shorter version
than the one that was included
in the agenda more focused the other one
was
providing a lot more detail and
background and answer questions but i
don't intend to go through all of that
detail now
um but i thought it was quite useful to
point out newton abbott
is and has been a market town for 800
years
so it's always adapted and remain
relevant to the needs of its community
the plans that we're looking to take
forward
are the latest evolution of all of that
so
in the last 10 11 years the council has
been looking at
plans for what can happen to help newton
aberdeen it's in its latest evolution
uh and this slide just sets out a number
of those different plans
um and bits of work and studies that
have been going on
in all that time and all of those bits
of work were
done with engagement from the local
community from
councillors from key stakeholders who
are involved
in what goes on in the town um and the
surrounding area
and through all of this work um visions
have been developed and and the common
theme and we've brought this together
um from from those various documents
uh is looking at newton averages devon's
premier market town
um it's a wider population it's well
connected
uh and meets everybody's needs
so throughout those plans and ideas one
of the comments that's always made is
it's all well and good having these
plans but people want to see things
happen
um and you know the amount of times you
might go to to meetings and
conversations where you think
okay we've discussed this we've agreed
where we want to go to let's move on
and one of the key components of that is
the ability to enable that to happen
and that's through from an opportunity
so the future high street funds presents
us with an opportunity
to deliver on that vision um the scope
of what we can do is set by government
um i don't think we can
shy away from that this what we've had
to do
is look at what projects uh and
initiatives and ideas that we've had
collectively over that time
and identify which of the projects we've
all agreed as the way forward
can we access and bring forward through
this particular funding stream
so whilst there are other bits that may
not have come forward
there are plenty that we've we've
historically and continuously said
this is where we want the town to be
moving forward towards so the scope is
is looking at physical changes um things
that are going to help
our economy um newton have it's been
quite resilient
um throughout the years and always done
very well
um and we're looking at you know what
opportunities there are to bring more
um for those who use the town regularly
are those who
are within the local area but don't use
it as much so what can we do to help
bring those people in
to the town um and also looking at uh
you know evolving to to future habits
and changes of
of how people get out and about and uh
you know trying to increase and improve
the cycle
infrastructure the pedestrian experience
um and also we can look at the changes
to building so there's
three main projects that we put forward
for the bid there's the markets quarter
which also includes the cinema
it's queen street enhancements and then
the national cycle network
improvements so i'd just like to take
through
the component parts in a little bit more
detail
so the markets quarter centers around
the market hall on the alexandra cinema
so the building was originally designed
as a corn exchange but split into a
marker hall
and a theater which then became a cinema
we want we monitor the footfall into the
hall on the daily basis
uh and we've noticed or we've seen the
decrease over the last five years so
this is a national trend this isn't just
something
uh unique to newtonia but the markets as
a whole
are suffering as a result of competition
of change in consumer habits
um and we need to to do something that
um addresses that particular issue
so uh deal the building so we saw a 35
decrease in footfall over the last five
years
so taking that image of what the
building used to be look like
what we've been looking at is developing
a cultural quarter
um a flexible mixed-use space which
retains the character
of the building but leaves us much more
flexible and agile as to how we use the
building
moving forward how adaptable it can be
and how it can be used
to offer not just the daytime economy
but also extending into the evening
economy
and this is an artist's impression of
what it could look like
but we're also the best this image is
sort of
a step removed and again an artist's
impression of from within the alexander
cinema building
looking through uh and into the market
hall there's there's still a lot more
work for us to
to do this but this is part of the uh
the imagery and the
the how it could work um but we know
that it's not
um uncharted territory uh this is ultron
in greater manchester you can see
similarities to
how the building looks and how it's laid
out to what our thoughts are so we've
we've been looking at what works
elsewhere what the opportunities are
uh and being able to visualize how this
could work is actually um
quite reassuring and you can see on the
bottom bullet point uh in austin they
saw
an increase in footfall by 25 percent
from taking
making those changes to to that building
we undertook engagement as part of the
submission
to the future high street fund um uh
consultants on our behalf
uh uh interviewed or surveyed 877 people
99 of whom had the tq postcard
postcode the other one of the nex
postcodes are all
local respondents um and looking at the
importance of the markets to the town
and and it's still seen as very
important but not a destination in its
own right
and that the main the main demographics
or people who
um you know who come in and spend money
in the town and
uh but they're not necessarily going to
be using it so
we understand that the potential is
there there is a need to appeal
a lot more broadly um and that there is
widespread support for enhancements to
be made
we know that we can't carry on exactly
as we are we need to look at
how it might change and so this is going
to enable us to to move on
and look at that uh there's also
um as part of that obviously going to be
changes to the cinema building which we
know
for two to three weeks a year is used by
uh mad max the um local amateur
dramatic group and the friends of the
alexander theatre who are made up of
members of that group and others in the
community
who are keen to see the theater element
retained
in the building and that's always been
an intention is to have the
flexible space to allow theater to carry
on and different performance space
how exactly that's going to work is
still to be
developed and we've had very productive
meetings with
the group to talk about how we move
forward and we've drafted a memorandum
of understanding
which we've shared with the group about
how we want to work together moving
forward
moving on to the cinema building we've
known for quite some time so we've had
survey work in the past looking at
demand
and need for spaces and we know that
there is a
demand for at least four screen cinema
within the town
we continue to work with scott cinemas
to bring that forward
we did look at bringing forward a scheme
back in 2018 but ultimately had to
shelve it because it wasn't viable
um the future high street fund has now
allowed us to revisit that plan
um and you can see from sorry
from the slide some of the benefits um
that come from
from cinemas this is survey work in the
latter bullet points i won't hold on to
this slide too long because
it's a lot of information the slides
will be available
um as part of the um the notes or the
minutes from this meeting
um but the the latter bullet points
are based on um some survey work that
was done on the return to the cinema so
what the impact of lockdown has been um
and you can see that it contributes
quite very positively to uh
sort of the social side um and
you know a lot of age groups are missing
out on that activity they would have
otherwise used so there's a lot of
benefits in in how the town recovers
from the lockdown measures and from
covert that the cinema can help
address and bring forward and it's also
you know looking at that building
looking at the cultural quarter
more widely there's been investments
recently in newton's place with the town
council
and in the the library from devon county
council uh and to another iconic
building in the town up to the market
hall
and we're looking to to invest in uh
repurposing that
for modern life moving on to the cycle
networks hopefully you can see all this
uh well enough there's it highlights
a number of different routes in and
around the town there's been a lot of
investment
to bring forward um improved cycle links
from newton abbott to the wider area
so good trails out to bobby tracy uh to
um king's kurzweil on sorbet
there is work in bringing forward the
team valley
of the sort of teen estuary trail but
it's known that
one you can get the the route into the
town but getting in through the town
center
is a little more challenging so um some
of the money from the future high street
fund
will be brought in to enhance those
links within the town centre and
hopefully you can see the purple
lines on the map are where the future
high street fund
money will be invested to make those
improvements
active travel as a concept and and
something that we're
very keen uh as an authority to to push
forward
um not only does it help with the the
climate change agenda in
shifting the way people move around the
towns but it's also very good for
for well-being um and an opportunity for
newtonia to lead the way
in delivering active travel um for the
physical and mental
well-being benefits that they that that
brings
we did again untook some survey work uh
looking at the improvements before we
submitted the bid
and a lot of strong support for
improvements to the cycle network
low numbers of people currently use
bicycles for shopping
but there is potential there um that
more
would start to use and appreciate the
small sample size um
but it backs sort of national trends and
information that we see that
if the infrastructure is in place people
will use it
looking onto the improvements on queen
street these are aimed more the
pedestrians than cyclists obviously
they're
improving the um space uh
and having it less dominated by cars
will encourage more cyclists down there
but
by having wider footpaths it's much
better for the pedestrians for people
looking to use the shops up and down
and other facilities along queen street
but so it's just a better public realm
and enhancements for for pedestrians
it's quite cramped at the moment quite
narrow
there's a lot of street furniture uh and
as you're moving down especially on
busier days
or busier times of the day it can become
too narrow and force people out
into the road or between parked cars so
it would create a much better
uh feel for the place um and again
we we undertook some survey work before
we submitted the bid
um and the support for seeing
improvements to
those facilities to widen it for
pedestrians
and also making sure it's well
maintained and looked after there is
still more work to be done
on the detail which will be the next
stage of the bid once the funding is
secured
to to design that up and uh picking up
council hocking's point of
um being mindful of how it's all going
to work and how it's going to be
maintained
uh and that'll be a sort of the next
step
they'll be quite useful just to share
this um slide
on occupancy along queen street um
to show how much it's changed in the
last 20 years and it stands out nearly
half of the number of shops that existed
20 years ago have now changed to other
uses
um so no real change in number of
takeaways but in increasing cafes
more residential more services such as
barbershops
um so it's the dynamic is changing
that's something that's quite notable
things like the grimsey review which was
cited in in the report
um showing that how people use town
centers is changing
and what people want from their
experience is changing uh and the
dynamics of how people use that
the number of shops or pop and shop is
decreasing
um and so you know we're looking at
longer dwell time
so it's not necessarily that people are
going to want to just get in and out and
off they go
they're going to stay a little bit
longer so having an improved
customer experience and pedestrian
experience is quite important
so the next steps um once the funding
has been agreed and secured uh to
develop detailed engagement plans so to
to um to engage with those who fed back
into the process today to start going
through
much more detailed delivery plans uh the
cinema
project will go beyond the lifetime of
the future hashtag funds but we can
utilize
team bridge money for later stages you
can still invest after the march 2024
deadline um so there'll be uh
sort of more upfront money um for that
um
so the plan applications and also
detailed plans uh the cycling
enhancements within the next
uh calendar year with devon county
leading on that
and the queen street plans a little bit
longer
over the next two years moving forward
and just to summarize uh you know the
the outcomes that we're seeking from
from this bid um to to deliver on the
vision
to create to develop newtonia devon's
premier market town
uh see an increase of footfall into the
town centre uh
bro much broaden the appeal um for who
comes to the town to see that as that
destination
uh investment into the evening economy
uh and you know lengthening the time
people will dwell within the town
and being adaptable and changeable to
the next iteration
of newton albert and that ends
the presentation so if you have any
questions
please let me know thank you thank you
just hold the questions i did promise i
would come back to mark hockey before we
moved into
executive questions so mike you've seen
the presentation is there anything
you briefly want to uh cover and please
do
well thank you um leader um
i mean the presentation isn't that much
different
from the original presentation that's
been said a bit more
information and whatever you want there
um
i am still very concerned about the way
that we're trying to
um use queen street as as a lever to
get the get the funding i don't believe
um queen street the the
way that queen street is being predicted
as
uh taking all this parking away and not
replacing it when this
first came about the the parking that
was going to be
um taken from queen street was going to
be put into
um cricket field car park um i
appreciate
the surveys have been done in respect of
how many cars are using
each car part within the tiny center and
the spaces that are available
but these the people that actually stop
in queen street or
basically pop and shop they just pull up
pull it go in and do a quick
get what they want quickly and then
they're away they're not the sort of
people that uh normally
go and park in the car parks and and use
italian center they are just a quick pop
and shop
and that is my worry that is what's
what's worrying me
and the businesses within queen street
that that
um will be taken away from them
queen street itself yes um the officer
is quite right
um queen street is is changing and it
has been changing
um has the time centers pulled
more towards uh the center like market
walk
and the businesses within courtney
street have actually pulled the town
center towards it rather than whereas
queen street was quite
making quite a long time center if you
know what i'm saying so yes it has
changed um but there's businesses but if
we take away the parking certainly down
the bottom and where you
which we call is take away alley um
they're they will they will have a
problem with people
again pop and shop they just pull up go
and get their
takeaways and then off again um
and that that is a big problem and a
worry and a concern
so although i understand what the
why team bridge have said what they said
and brought the plans forward
and using queen street as a way of
getting this funding
i can understand that i don't agree with
it
and i won't support it um because i do
not think this is the right way of going
we tried many years ago as a tang
council tried to get the top end of
queen street pedestrianized
devon county council refused um
refused it at that point um saying that
there was a road going through and that
we couldn't
uh pedestrianize in fact even
even the businesses didn't really want
it pedestrianized
so by doing what you're doing i do not
believe that this is the right way and
and
although um you know nothing's really in
the report really changed my idea
um i well i just hope that it will go
through
and i'm not doubting that you you will
vote it through now
um i just hope that you will perhaps
talk to the businesses
talk to the town council and actually
listen to what we're trying to say
people have lived and worked and shopped
in newton about all their lives
we know exactly what's going on we know
newton abbott
and i don't think that some of the ideas
that you're getting from
other places up up and down the country
are necessarily what's going to work
well in other
we all know now even if just one last
little thing sir and i'll
finish even now we know that on
at dinner time on a saturday
the market the more everything goes dead
on a
on a thursday afternoon everything goes
day why
because traditionally that has been the
time when newton abbott have basically
grinded to a hold anyway thank you for
letting me speak
that's fine thank you very much mike
appreciate it nina cancer jefferies
thank you leader um thanks uh for the
presentation and
thanks um councillor hocking um
i had a little bit prepared earlier and
then i've kind of changed it listening
to
everything everyone said today um i just
hope that
you will look through all the
presentations or the paperwork that's
gone before
um just to go forward um
in terms of what's happening um
i think the tdc have worked tirelessly
over the past
ten years towards this bid to win a
successful bid for newton abbott and i
understand
um some of the discussions that have
been had with the community and there
has been
plenty of consultation that has gone out
and discussion and i don't expect that
to stop
um in the first instance um
and then they've gone back to reimagine
the original bid in the light of covid
and the
restricted funding that's available and
to ensure that it really remains
transformative and meets the government
criteria as well
so although i hear what you're saying
about their
restrictions on car parking i think that
is
one of the discussions that we will have
to take forward in terms of looking at
the detail and what will work and as
people say
talking to the people that have shots
there and living there
in the locality i think it would be
remiss to ignore
how um vital and healthy discussion on
the concerns
and the positives of such a scheme um
would be and just to thank again
councillor hopkins for putting forward
some of those today
um no scheme is going to come forward
such as this size without those
um those kinds of discussions and
in order to make sure it's robust enough
needs to happen
um so
any reject regeneration is a risk but
it's reassuring to hear actually today
that despite those rotations
um based on historical experience and i
can understand
you know newton abbott has had quite a
lot of um building in the past that has
had been hit and miss shall we say i
think
um we have to take risk in order to
to revitalize areas and to bring forward
new investments and particularly
after what has happened over the past 12
months with covert 19.
it outlines in that report some
businesses actually that have sadly
not been able to survive the pandemic on
the high street in the
nether and we need to look at how can we
reimagine and reinvigorate the high
street to encourage new business in
whether that's the market new walkways
younger people coming in a nighttime
economy
new cinemas if we don't take the risk we
won't really know
um so it's good that there's still a
willingness to support the bid
and to drive forward that vision for
everyone
um that works for all so i just wanted
to acknowledge that
i've heard that newt nabba is a town
with a proud heritage obviously i'm a
deaf and girl so i know that anyway
um and that i feel that really listening
to everything there are still
very much exciting times ahead um i'm
looking forward to further engagement
around the detail of this beard
um working with local communities and
making sure
that people's voices are heard and
brought to the table so we can make sure
we have got something
that works for everybody within this
community and not only do i feel that
it's good
for newt nava but i feel that it would
be good for all the towns of cambridge
to have something as a vibrant market
town
so i'm just going to finish there and
that's something i'll speak if they want
to thank you
thank you very much nina so i've got
next jackie hook which are killing
stephen purses
jackie
thank you leader um yeah i'm speaking
not only as an executive member but
um also district ward member and
currently county councillor for the new
now but town centre
area um and it's not often we get the
chance to confirm and approve our
acceptance of 9.2 million pounds of
government funding
to invest in the future prosperity of
the main town in our district
and this represents a real opportunity
for newton abbot to define its role as
the premier town of the area
serving not only the needs of its
residents but those of the surrounding
area
and not for getting visitors to our
district it will enable businesses of
all kinds to prosper
the environment of our town center to be
improved and the quality
of life of the residents to be enhanced
and for me this feels very much like the
culmination of a journey which began
with the vision
expressed by the people of newton abba
in the town's community plan
of 2008 and on the slides we saw a
number of other documents
that have all gone through public
consultation that contained
that vision that was in that original
community plan
the community then that plan then
provided the context for newton abbott's
neighborhood plan
which was drawn up in conjunction with
the people of the town
who voted for it in the referendum held
in 2016
following extensive public consultation
and it is the town council's and the
town's neighborhood plan
which states that newton abbott is an
ambitious town which positively embraces
sustainable development and change
and just to pick out some of those
things from the neighborhood plan
that are part of the vision of the town
held by the people of the town
so the priorities are to facilitate
initiatives which maintain and improve
the quality and socio-economic viability
of the town
to open up better cross-town connections
for walk-in and cycling
to green the streets through tree shrub
and flower planting
to address traffic issues in the town
centre including the potential for
remodeling traffic priorities in queen
street
and to encourage the development of an
evening economy
now all of those elements of the town's
vision and priorities for the town
center
are reflected in the four elements of
the future high street proposals
and in addition to the support the
support the town's neighborhood plan
gave to the proposals we've already seen
that
the district council carried out its own
consultation
which we've just seen the results of
which
showed a clear majority support for all
the four elements of the proposals
including the queen streak proposals and
it has to be mentioned that actually
some of those responses
were pushing for a more transformational
um approaching queen street
um that possibly you know might not be
possible obviously more
discussions are possible but um you know
there is an element of our population
that would like to see something more
transformational happening queen street
than is proposed but
we need to find a solution so in my
opinion we can proceed with confident
confident that we have the majority
support of the town's residents
and confident that this district council
is delivering the residents wishes
however it is important that we continue
to consult on the fine detail of the
proposals
to ensure we achieve the best outcome
not only for
residents businesses and visitors
now but for those of the future
we must continue to listen and seek to
allow for differences of opinion
about the detail and the way forward but
without losing the overall
transformational vision that is behind
these well thought out and interlinked
proposals
and this i'm sure is the desire of all
stakeholders um
and lastly i mean the grimsey review has
been mentioned
i to be honest didn't know who grimsey
was but he is a long-term active senior
retailer
and has carried out other retail reviews
um
in this country but you know i i would
urge you if you haven't read it yet to
read that review because it really is
very inspirational about the way forward
for town centers
and includes lots of case studies and
and as far as i'm concerned why wouldn't
you listen to experts
or why wouldn't you look at what's
worked in the rest of the country
because the evidence is very clearly
there but that report was just june last
year and it was about building back
better
after covid19 for town centres and just
to i mean there's so many good quotes
you could take
from that but just one um from
mr grimsey himself um shopping is just
one of the challenges facing town
centres
high streets are inextricably bound up
with climate change
seemingly intractable transport problems
crime
worsening public health loss of
community and shared sense of belonging
breaking this nexus of problems is key
to the promise of a better life for all
that opportunity is now within touching
distance but
to seize it we need to let go of the
past it rests on us all
not just decision makers in local and
central government but in communities
everywhere to make it happen
the most successful high streets and
town centres will need to change to
reflect
the communities they serve by
transforming themselves into community
hubs
playing to their strengths of offering
human interaction
and unique sense of place and community
so i believe the future high street
funds provide us with this opportunity
for newton abbott
i have no hesitation whatsoever in
welcoming this funding
the proposals and recommendations in the
report
as the start of our journey to transform
our town
into that unique center and community
hub of the future
thank you absolutely thank you very much
uh jackie
richard councillor keenan thank you very
much
sorry richard can just ask people to
take their hands down when you've spoken
richard you carry on thanks thank you
very much leader
um i certainly welcome this investment
of 9.2 million pounds
it could have been more it should have
been more um and i
you know i'd welcome certainly and
suddenly that
small proportion of that investment into
our high street
especially into our shared space scheme
that we have ready to go
but um you know can i just say
i disagree with councillor hawking and i
disagree with him because
uh as a a past retailer of two made
two shops in in two towns in within team
bridge
um that you know over the years
uh 15 years of being in that business um
i would certainly now if i had the
uh a younger feel to me in energy
i would certainly be investing in a shop
in queen street
and because the footfall there will be
certainly
um increased through this
investment and that's what it's all
about
those retailers within the town
have got to think towards this will
increase the football
this will increase the amount of people
coming through my door
and looking at my what i'm selling
buying
and the longer they stay in the town as
well the more shops that they go to
so the parking side of it has to be you
know
reduced so that people stay longer the
the one stop into one shop and out
doesn't benefit the next shot down or
the next shot down
so this is is it strategically right and
correct
um so i i totally support that can i
also mention
um something that counselor hocking is
probably all aware of
um but we will we are working very
closely
with a um a new tenant myself and
council jeffries
for the old post office so that is
ongoing at the moment and we hope to
bring you some news soon
on that but um i certainly welcome this
thank you very much leader thank you
richard and for
insight from your own business
experience so uh stephen councillor
person
thank you leader this may well be a left
field question
and if so please rule me out of order
but as you know i'm very keen
on residential high quality residential
buildings within our high streets as
the big retailers and the big shops go
and we build these smaller community
hubs
and to to prosper they need more people
and
more people living in town centres uh is
a way forward
and certainly i understand the planning
laws have changed and
uh large shops can now without i think
having to apply for planning commission
be converted to reta uh to residential
uh something we need to keep an eye on
to make sure
we do get a high quality mix of
residential
and i just the question really is is
does this plan in any way
link up to that potential or possibility
or
can discussions be somewhere included if
a a greater residential offering is
going to come forward
can this plan accommodate and and sort
of
be mindful of what might be coming
residential wise
uh in the future so um i'm not gonna
you're not out of order stephen uh it's
a fair question
in terms of um how the center and
another
might develop in and change in years to
come
what i'm to do is ask one of the
officers to pick that up
at the end i'm going to get through the
speakers if i may because i think that's
a
connected but not directly relevant
question if that's all right thank you
alastair counselor julius
thank you leader um and and a big thank
you to neil
and his team uh for for bringing this
forward
um it's been a long time coming and
and for me i really really welcome this
because the future of newton abbott
clearly
uh is is at a tipping point and unless
we do something
um newton abbott like market towns and
high streets
everywhere in the uk we will just cease
to have
a relevance um so so to take those sort
of various bits
in order queen street um there is no
removal
of parking uh at the eastern end
beyond the imperial um and all those pop
and stop
places will will have the same amount of
parking
that they ever have had but at the
western end
uh up towards courtney street um it's a
horrible experience there's no space on
the pavements
uh and um like most of us
i i've had little reason to to visit uh
newton abbott or anywhere
else for that matter in the past month
but but when i
had to go to the bank the other day uh
to get uh some documents signed
it was a really unpleasant experience
just walking
that that hundred yards uh to the bank
with people having to walk out into the
streets and the like
so i really really welcome uh
additional space uh and and improvements
and i'd love to see some trees
and planters and just a a friendly
pedestrian area um the cinema
the cinema is is absolutely i think
a key um i do believe that people
think that going to the cinema is is
one of our major sort of leisure issues
i have a little bit of an interest uh to
declare here
in the i'm a member of the management
committee of the village cinema
in ipple pen and we know how people
have really missed going to the cinema
uh during
during lockdown so i very much support
that
um in terms of the building work uh i
was a little bit
concerned uh about the risk assessments
on page 111 having just uh
gone through the last uh three years of
a
of a a major 13 million plus
uh building project and knowing that the
things that everybody said was oh we
don't need to worry about that so you
don't need to worry about
this actually we really did have to
worry about that
and things like asbestos um
on old buildings you just never know
where you're going to find
asbestos similarly the moment you start
digging into the ground
um you just have absolutely absolutely
no idea what's going to happen
uh down there particularly i suspect
it in a place uh like the center of
newton abbott where you could well
find archaeological remains and all
kinds of things
so so i i really hope our officers have
absolutely looked at those risk
assessments
uh in in absolute detail
and put in the maximum uh that we need
to cover
ourselves if anything sort of goes wrong
there
and then uh coming to the the alex
and the and the market hall um when
when this first came up um
i i spoke about that um
some years ago and i did have concerns
because i feel that although
clearly we need to improve the market
hall and and that is
side of things is pretty obvious and in
the pictures there
uh we we saw uh images of the one in
altering them
um in terms of what we want to do with
with the alex i'm really glad that we're
talking uh to um to
to the various stakeholders there
because i i
i just don't quite see in all of this
exactly what we intend to end up with
uh and and for me i i really would
welcome
a space where uh theater could take
place
can take place uh where where dining can
take place
a real place to go um
in newton abbott which i think would
bring people in
and also lead to um to a sort of
a regeneration of our arts a place
perhaps
where you could hold a small concert
that that type of thing
music i'd just really love to see that
um i i actually sorry nearly finished
later okay so i i also
um like like some others
remember the old market
of old i remember the boyle sweet man
and and the
[ __ ] and and i'd love to see that
kind of vibrancy
uh come back to our market square i'm
aware of the
the proposals for the post office and
very
very much support what i've heard so far
uh from the people
who who are coming forward uh with with
this
and then finally i'd also like to
support councillor persa
in in his comments about housing i
really think
i i'd love to see some housing proper
housing
in our town center um some quality
housing
i think that'd be really really good in
in european cities
uh the the the best flats and the nicest
places
in the town center thank you good enough
wonderfully thank you very much sorry so
that's sorry i need to apologize but uh
once we got into europe i thought we'd
better stop the global trot
um and now i'm going to move to martin
ridley and andrew mcgregor
so martin thank you leader i will be
briefed i do promise
um i i think all of the ideas that are
bringing more community bringing more
evening life
bringing more retail
leisure retail uses are really going
with the trend that we need to be
following so i i support all of these
i won't repeat all the things that
people said other than that
like council do you hurt i went to the
bank and ended up walking down the
middle of the street because there was
enough space to walk on the pavement
and it's not a nice experience we can
improve it
these plans can be it will be
a significant improvement in our pity
the middle of
the middle of uh newton abbot because it
doesn't have the the wonderful things
that we have in dualish with the
the greenery and the spaces and the
wildlife right in the middle of town
which does enhance the community
tremendously but the greening of green
street is a great step in the right
direction
removing the cars and removing the focus
on cars and increasing the focus on
people
is a great step i'll leave you with one
thought
my early career i started working in the
mid-80s
right in the middle of coventry plenty
of parking plenty of retail
opportunities
it was a ghost town it was it was
horrible
i think the 60s have done us no favors
and the um
the designs that we have now will
produce a far far
better uh result the emphasis on markets
is
really key with the local shop local
trend with people wanting
to buy from real people uh which does uh
complement the online shopping that is
here today
so i fully endorse all the proposals and
i love the way it's going forward with
being very collaborative as well
thank you thank you martin and andrew
council mcgregor
uh thank you um i'll start with europe i
mean if if you take dillingham in
germany
or villabella the redow in in portugal
or
seville in spain even these are all
places that have followed a similar path
in terms of reducing the amount of cars
in the town center reducing the amount
of parking
and attracting funnily enough more
people into the town centre
to enjoy um clean air environment
um a relaxed opportunity to sit down and
commute through the through the town
in in the uk i mean you look at oxford
oxford is a is a very old
educational town with beautiful
buildings and much of the town is now
pedestrianized and again it's about
getting people to stay
within the town centre and enjoy the
environment within the town centre
i think in terms of newton abbot uh and
the actual fund itself i think we have
to
to remember that the fund is based on
providing a transformational look to
newton abbott
if we don't provide the transformational
look we won't get the funding it's as
simple as that you know and in some
respects
whilst they've expected a
transformational look they've also tied
our hands slightly to
that the transformation can't be as good
as we'd like it to be but we have to
make the best of that and i think going
forward
you know i think if we we didn't have
the funding and we didn't have the
opportunity to transform the town center
places like the alex and the and the
market area that we have at the moment
would continue to suffer from entropy
start to decay start to look even worse
and all we'd end up with is a dirty
polluted town centre with fairly
unpleasant looking buildings
and i think that's what we're trying to
avoid here and look to the future and
generate
real interest in people coming to
newton abbott to stay to become a
neighborhood rather than a shopping
destination
thank you for that andrew i'm kind of
going to come shortly to
uh neil blaine he had a place in
commercial services to pick up some of
the points in particular
associated issue of potential
residential
uh and i'm mindful of course that while
the government have changed some of the
planning
uh regulations which would enable
resident
retail to convert to residential it it
needs to be done sympathetically well
but
put new on june notice it's coming your
way and i want to thank everyone for
all of your comments um for me there are
two
headline issues one is do we agree
newton abbott should be
devon's premier market town if we do
then we certainly can't
stand by and do nothing something must
be done and here is 9.2 million of
government funding
to help us achieve that but don't forget
when you look at the numbers it's not
just that
we are putting in as in public sector
primarily teamwork
we're putting in something another six
million on that
so this is a 15 million huge statement
of confidence and faith
in newton abbott as a growing and
vibrant market town
which really does stand for most in all
market towns in devon
now that's the vision that is the vision
but change is never easy and letting go
of the past
and moving to something new is never
easy we've got experience of that and
uh at a different level but if you think
in timothy when we
propose changing the old jolly roger
play area to what's on the den now
people have posted they thought it was
awful it was going to affect trade but
when we did it
um what was the reaction actually people
were coming from torquay and exeter
into timothy they were buying the ice
creams and the coffees and doing more
and some of the local bed and breakfast
said that they were getting more trade
not less
it was good and when we pushed ahead
with
by michael's field and um changing that
into
uh sports grounds which enabled us to do
a broad
meadow which enabled morrisons which
enabled 11 million to come into the
council
and enable the council to deliver the
theater space
in timmouth again to replace the old
theater
you know it's a big investment and it's
created jobs in terms of s3 core
so when i look at newton abbott uh i
find it interesting that 99 percent of
the people had tq postcodes
and i wondered about all those people
who live in ex-7 dollars gx6
uh kenton starcross x-minster beyond
and why they're not in newton but they
are newton abbott's market
surely people in kent and starcross
excellence that
they should be thinking themselves i i
want to go to newton what's the offer
what's the attraction
so we're missing out aren't we we're
missing out on part of
the offer right across our district that
this is bigger than simply
another people should be thinking i am
going to go to
i'm going to go there and shop it has
much to offer
it's a pleasant environment i can have a
coffee i can have lunch i can do things
i can stay on in the evening and i can
see a show or music or
whatever it might be and a market
experience to be proud of
you know because people do like markets
there's no doubt about that
and i think i should speak up for
shipping containers because
kazakhstan said the new cinema will look
like two shipping containers well i'm
noticing a grand designs program
uh where someone actually bought two
shipping containers and put them across
each other
and converted them into absolutely
fantastic home
uh so there's much to be shared with
shipping containers
but also if you go to bristol so you
don't need to go to europe you can just
go
to bristol uh in the next one you know
two counties away really
um and if you go to the harbour side
there you will see
a shipping container village not rusting
wrecks of things that were sort of
stranded in the series canal
but marvelous structures insulated and
they've got
retailers in them and fish and chip
shops and pizza places and a butcher and
candle makers and all sorts in there and
it's brought
life to the harbour side it's a place
where people go
so that leads me back to something even
closer exeter
and if you think about the key in exeter
say 40 years ago
you probably couldn't pay people to have
gone there if you remember the
under arches there were there was a a
place you could buy
wood there are panel beaches paint car
sprayers
car mechanic places and all that sort of
thing
but it wasn't really a place you want to
go and spend any time unless you had to
be there and exeter had a vision about
that key
about turning it into a place where
people would go and wanted to be and
residential came with it as you know
because
those flats came in time but they had to
get the public sector investment in
first
in order to make it a place that was
desirable and i was there over the
weekend i
you know went for a long walk um and
the piazza at the end of the canal would
come out basin
absolutely brand with people buying
coffees and
bacon burgers and goodness what else uh
or bacon bats i should have said
absolutely and cyclists in loads of
cyclism
on our way through or whatever that was
a thing but people were there it was
vibrant it was a joyous place to be
and i really don't feel that um you know
the
absence of people from newton abbot is
something that we can allow you to
continue the figures show there is a
decline the people
show the figures show that people are
voting with their
feet and their feet are taking them in a
different direction and this is a moment
in time where we can seize it
and hopefully secure it and so i just
wanted to say to you as well a couple of
other buildings
that i think of note if you've been to
liverpool there's a huge building
and when you look at it it's designed to
look like a ship coming into
into port uh and that led me on to think
about the western morning news building
in plymouth which again won awards
i don't think it is the western morning
news building now um
but in time i've no idea whether the new
cinema in newton albert will be seen as
an award-winning
it doesn't really matter if it is or it
isn't is it what it needs to be
is attracting people in to go and see a
film there are three
cinemas that i know of in exeter with a
population of 120 000
and we're proposing one cinema in newton
abbott which has a population of what
40ish 50 000 but it has a very wide
hinterland as people like me who have
choices about whether
you go into exeter uh on an evening and
see a film or whether i go to newton
abbott
why shouldn't i go to newton albert with
a brand new full screen cinema
and then maybe have some entertainment
after and stay on and catch up with
friends in these
postcode times which i hope we're gonna
get so
my summary is if it's not now when if
it's not this then what what is better
than what is the vision there
and if newton rabbit isn't and doesn't
deserve to be devon's premier market
town
show me a place that does because i
think we're on the money
of the moment and we really do need to
move ahead
and i'm going to ask neil blaney now to
top what i've just said
and tell us tell us why we're doing the
right thing
neil and deal with the housing too i'll
uh i don't know if i can top that i will
pick up on the housing point though
um we can't change the the bid as
submitted
it is what it is um but that we are
looking at
options and and possibilities for town
center living
so there's different uh opportunity
areas the sites that have permission
that
um have stalled uh and there's assets
that we own that we can look at
bring them forward through another route
so uh for council of person we are
actively looking at that it isn't part
of this particular bid
um part of it is having projects ready
to go
um because the time scale for for
delivering these projects and spending
the money is
end of march 2024 um we're in a position
with the projects we put
forward um there'll be other funding
opportunities i'm sure
as we move forward and so it's making
sure we are continuing developing those
plans obviously we've got the team
bridge 100
which will contain some of those and
making sure we do that and not just for
newton abbott it's it's looking at
opportunities in all towns
um where residential is the government
is making it easier
um i think with permitted development i
i don't know the the finer details as to
how much
control there is over how it looks uh
whether it's just straight conversion
and
off you go so um but but that's
definitely up there the grimsy review
talks about the importance not only of
the experience and the destination but
increasing residential in the town
centre more football more permanent
presence
uh the active evening economy is
enhanced by having more people who
are just there anyway all the time so um
it's
this ties in well with that in that you
know we're looking at more residential
coming in
there are plenty of things for people to
be doing and wanting to be there as a
destination and somewhere to live
lovely thank you very much now um i know
no one asked to go into part two but can
i just check for the purposes of the
minutes
does anyone wish to discuss any aspect
of the report
that was provided in exempt um
information no all right thank you very
much
i just want to be clear that i've asked
that uh neil can i ask you to put up
then the final recommendations for
council
are onto the screen
okay so this is the um
so this is the version that i showed
before with the track changes
yeah in there and then there's the
tidied up version
so just a clean version so just to be
clear then
uh if you just hold it there thanks so
uh
executive is asked to resolve to accept
the ministry
of housing communities and local
government funding of nine point
nine point two million but you've got
the exact figure there offered as part
of the futurishing program
and that two the market will propose to
be approved in principle
further engagement with key stakeholders
will continue on detail
design phase for the internal layer and
the executive recommends the council as
detailed in this report
the national psychology two proposals as
paragraph 2.2 reports an associative
budget
are approved queen state proposals and
the associated council budget
so are approved to mark all proposals an
associated budget are approved
um the council budget uh of
991 thousand nine twenty one for the
cinema uh
is approved and that we give delegated
authority to the head of place in
commercial services
in consultation with the executive
member for economy and jobs and the
chief finance officer to finalize
details
as set out there and i want that for
clarity um
nina are you happy to propose those uh
slightly
changed recommendations
i am leader thank you super and may i
invite a second
please i can't see anyone so you'll have
to call i'll reckon
the second all right who was the first
uh jackie jackie yes sir so take jackie
seconding uh and can we take that off
the screen then and then we're going to
move to a vote
and i'm going to just just for the
purposes of the minute on this occasion
i'm going to ask for a named vote so
sarah if you would just
uh take them take the um i'll take the
names down
councillor connet four councillor
dewhurst
four councillor jackie hook
or councillor keeling or
counselor jefferies or
councillor mcgregor or
councillor four councillor taylor
councillor wrigley
thank you very much and just for
everyone's clarity and particularly for
those who may be watching on youtube so
that stands as our
resolution and our recommendation to
council and that goes to cancer on the
next council meeting is the 22nd of
april isn't it
yes yes yeah that's where the
recommendations are then consider the
game
by the full membership of the council
okay all right
thank you very much that concludes then
the future issue and i want to close by
thanking all of the offices not just for
their time today
but also for all of their work over an
extended period of time
on the future high street fund bid and
all the work that's going on behind the
scenes i know there's a lot happening
and it's much appreciated and thank you
very much to all of the team on there
uh that i think then is the end of our
agenda is it not there's nothing else so
i've missed this
nothing else no so can i say uh
thank you to gordon for coming to speak
and also
to you mike for coming to speak and
setting out your views on the future
high street fund it is all
appreciated and good that you were able
to come today
and take part is valued so
thank you very much colleagues have a
lovely week thank you bye-bye
bye thank you cheers thank you leader
goodbye